Okay intro try one they'll probably cut that right yeah you don't have to say intro you just say you just start with what the show okay but I thought it would be if I go intro try and then nobody says intro try nobody says intro they just say that they just no it says intro that's good point that's good point so just talk all right just talk take you know I thought you said welcome to smart list I find it really fascinating you sleep in separate bedrooms it's yeah well because what are you doing you're just sleeping anyway so otherwise I'm a super light sleeper and I wake up at anything so that's why I'm a light
好吧，开场尝试第一版，他们可能会剪掉那个，对吧，是的，你不需要说“开场”，你只要说，你只要从节目开始，好吧，但我想如果我说“开场尝试”，然后没有人说“开场尝试”，没有人说“开场”，他们只是说，他们只是……不，它说“开场”，这倒是个好主意，这是个好主意，所以就随便聊聊，好吧，就随便聊聊，你知道的，我以为你会说“欢迎来到《聪明清单》”，我发现真的很奇妙，你们俩睡在不同的卧室里，是的，好吧，因为你在干嘛？反正你也就是睡觉，不然的话，我是个极度浅眠的人，一点风吹草动我就会醒，所以这就是为什么我睡眠也很
sleeper too well why don't you either connect some earmuffs to your bite plate or play play or or get an operation for your beloved or I gotta write this down yeah or strap a CPAP onto his helmet and get on with it which hide all of it his snoring is so bad it's just yeah it's he's just a snorer I can't so he's snoring so he does he's does he sleep with a CPAP machine he tried it it's it's it's like suffocating wait do it does Amanda or Alessandra snore no no do you guys I have but I don't sleep on my back yeah you so you snore on my back all right wait a second you're very defensive use when you sleep on your
浅，好吧，那为什么不把耳塞连到你的咬合板上，或者播放，或者，或者给你爱的人做个手术，或者，我得把这个记下来，是的，或者把一个CPAP呼吸机绑到他的头盔上，然后继续，这遮掩了这一切，他的呼噜声太响了，简直是，是的，他就是个打鼾大王，我受不了，所以他在打鼾，所以他，他睡觉用CPAP呼吸机吗？他试过，这，这，这就像是在窒息，等等，阿曼达或亚历山德拉打鼾吗？不，不，你们呢？我有，但我不是仰面睡觉的，是的，所以你在仰面……我仰面睡觉，好吧，等一下，你非常防备，当你仰面
back you do or you do sleep on your back therefore you snore I no longer sleep on my back because I'm tired of taking fire on my ribs from my my sleeping partner you know that's gonna get a kick or a punch and that means flip over and shut your mouth so I have how many how many times have you heard that sentence will it's gonna say why you're awake flip over shut your mouth and don't look at me is that that's a complete sentence that's how him and Alessandra met that's that we yeah I think actually that's a website that you know it's called just peg me okay well I don't want to keep our guests waiting too much longer we
睡觉时，你确实会，或者你确实是仰面睡觉，因此你打鼾，我不再仰面睡觉了，因为我厌倦了我的睡眠伴侣用胳膊肘撞我的肋骨，你知道的，那意味着会挨一脚或一拳，那就意味着翻过身去，闭上你的嘴，所以我听过多少次这句话了，威尔？我们要说的是，当你醒着的时候，翻过身去，闭上你的嘴，别看着我，这是一个完整的句子吗？这就是他和亚历山德拉相遇的方式，那是，我们，是的，我想实际上那是一个网站，你知道的，叫做“直接把我绑起来”好吧，我不想让我们的嘉宾等太久了，我们
have a very very special soul on today he's a stand-up comedian and he has hosted the popular television series United Shades of America since 2016 I love him he makes me laugh he makes me think two things that will try is really hard it but please welcome W come out bell hello there I want to know first first of all we we just call you come out because nobody says you right no people who don't know me but you we all know each other we're such good friends I heard about the begging and everything so just beg me dot-com we get into docking on the second half of the show stay tuned what is W what is the W
今天有一位非常非常特别的嘉宾，他是一位单口喜剧演员，自2016年起主持广受欢迎的电视系列节目《W. Kamau Bell：美国全貌》，我爱他，他让我笑，他让我思考，这是威尔会极力去做的两件事，但是请热烈欢迎W.卡毛·贝尔，大家好，我首先想知道，我们大家都直接叫你“卡毛”，因为没人叫你的“W”，对吧？不，不认识我的人会叫，但我们，我们大家都认识彼此，我们是那么好的朋友，我听说了“把我绑起来”和所有这些，所以就是“直接把我绑起来网”，我们会在节目的后半部分讨论搭讪，敬请期待，W到底是什么？W是什么？
Walter it's my dad's first name too so it's just that's a lovely name not really but thanks I mean there's never been a like maybe Walt Frasier that was the last cool Walter in culture but Wally there's some cool Wally's right Wally Fister first of all there's Wally like as in Wally there's that's a cool Wally he's just taking that your new sign off and our buddy Wally Fister is a cool that cinematographer slash director he's a cool guy wow we're already the cinematographers we're already yo yeah yeah yeah oh listen we're all about the arts will present you with my last Emmy well did I did present you this is the
沃尔特，这也是我爸爸的名字，所以它只是，那是个好名字，其实并没有，不过谢谢，我是说，从来没有一个，也许像沃尔特·弗雷泽，那是文化中最后一个酷酷的沃尔特了，但是沃利，有一些酷酷的沃利对吧？沃利·费斯特，首先，有一个像沃利那样的沃利，那是个酷酷的沃利，他只是在借用你的新标语，而我们的好朋友沃利·费斯特是一个很酷的摄影师兼导演，他是个酷哥，哇，我们已经在聊摄影师了，我们已经在，哟，是的，是的，噢，听着，我们全都是关于艺术的，威尔，我要把我的最后一个艾美奖颁给你，好吧，我真的给你颁过奖吗？这是
second time that this has happened to me I did present you with an Emmy so you guys first of all I just want to point out you guys are all Emmy winners I'm the only non Emmy winner here yeah yeah so congrats I bet you've got an Annie do you have an Annie I do I have a few did the Clio no I'm a guy no no will sorry you must have cut out there for a second yeah Clio no no I don't sorry that's okay yeah alright so come out you've done you know reading about you and and knowing you the very little bit that I do from Sundance we hung out for a while and really connected at least I thought so and and just adore you and adore your
我第二次遇到这种情况了，我确实给你颁过艾美奖，所以你们，首先，我只想指出，你们所有人都是艾美奖得主，我是这里唯一一个没有得过艾美奖的人，对，对，所以恭喜，我打赌你得过安妮奖，你有安妮奖吗？我有，我有几个，克里奥奖呢？不，我是一个，不，不，威尔，抱歉，你刚才一定断线了一会儿，是的，克里奥奖？不，不，我没有，抱歉，没关系，是的，好吧，所以卡毛，你做过，你知道的，读到关于你的资料，以及通过圣丹斯电影节对你仅有的一点了解，我们一起厮混了一段时间，并且真正建立了联系，至少我是这么认为的，并且简直崇拜你，崇拜你的
brain and adore your ambition to get the message out to people like us who are that bright and I love how I love your show how it just kind of the United Shades of America how it just kind of displays for us the questions and the answers in such a palatable way and it's it's so easily digestible and something everybody can understand so how did you think of the show and why did you think of the show you know I always wanted to do a show like this but there was no way that there's no path to these shows back in the day I would just sit on my couch watching Bourdain being like how do you get one
大脑，崇拜你把信息传递给像我们这样聪明的人的雄心壮志，我喜欢，我喜欢你的节目，那个《W. Kamau Bell：美国全貌》，它是如何为我们以如此美味易懂的方式展示问题和答案的，它是如此易于消化，而且是每个人都能理解的事情，所以你是怎么想到这个节目的？为什么会想到这个节目？你知道的，我一直想做这样一节目，但根本没有办法，过去根本没有通往这种节目的途径，我只会坐在沙发上看着安东尼·波登，心想，你怎么才能得到那样一个
of those yeah that's cool travel around and talking to people I knew that and really I had a show before this show called totally bias that was my first big break on FX and then when that show was canceled like see it just happened to be at the same time that CNN was like looking to break in another show like Bourdain so I was in the position of like them sort of pitching me on the idea which was really like great and also in position where Bourdain had so kicked the door wide open there was nothing I was gonna do that's gonna be like bigger than him so I really got a lot of freedom to sort of really make the show in
节目，是的，那太酷了，到处旅行并与人们交谈，我知道这一点，其实我在这个节目之前还有一个节目叫《完全偏见》，那是我在FX电视台的第一个重大突破，然后当那个节目被取消时，看吧，它刚好和CNN想要引进另一个像波登那样的节目的时间撞上了，所以我当时处于一种他们向我推销这个创意的处境，这真的很棒，而且也处于波登已经把门彻底踹开的处境，我做的任何事都不可能比他更大，所以我真的获得了很大的自由，去真正把这个节目打造成
Miami which has been great I love that first of all what was it that drove you to because as a stand-up you could just be you know doing Netflix specials or HBO specials or doing whatever and it seemed that you've kind of sure we all want that I wouldn't want to do that but you know what they like if they came to me and said hey we want to give you 20 million to do a stand-up special I'd say here's the here's the routing number for my bank no pass what do you want to say you thought I was gonna say pass but but my question I guess it to you is Kamau is you've decided that you have a obviously sort of built into what you do
我想要的，这真的很棒，我喜欢那样，首先是什么驱使你，因为作为一个单口喜剧演员，你本可以只是，你知道的，做网飞特辑或HBO特辑，或者做任何事，而且看起来你有点像，当然我们都想那样，我不想那样做，但你知道他们如果来到我这里说，嘿，我们想给你两千万让你做一个单口喜剧特辑，我会说，这是我银行的路由号码，不要错过，你想说什么？你以为我要说“错过”，但是我的问题，我想对你而言，卡毛，你已经决定了，你有一个，显然某种程度上融入了你所做的事情中
in your voice is this political bent this activist bent where that's a big part of who you are and what do you think it was that kind of what was that moment that or was there a seminal moment that drove you that way as opposed to just straight straight up stand-up I mean when I started doing stand-up I was just trying to be funny like everybody is trying to be funny and I really did not have any intention of being some sort of like cultural social whatever this voice is but I was raised by a black lady with opinions and so deep inside of me is it is that if something's wrong you're supposed to say
在你的声音里有这种政治倾向，这种积极分子倾向，这是你是谁以及你的所作所为的很大一部分，你认为是什么促使你走上这条路的？有没有一个决定性的时刻促使你走向那个方向，而不是单纯的直白单口喜剧？我是说，当我开始讲单口喜剧时，我只是想变得有趣，就像每个人都想变得有趣一样，我真的没有任何意图成为某种文化社会的，无论这声音是什么，但我是一个有主见的黑人女性抚养长大的，所以在我内心深处，如果有什么不对劲，你应该说
something and so I think as I got older and I had more of a stake in the world I started to pay more attention to the news and like I said I literally my mom's I used to I was an only child so I hang out with my mom a lot and she'd be around adults and so they would be in you know a lot of black folks who have come out of the civil rights movement who were like we have jobs now but we're still pretty pissed about the state of the world and I just heard these conversations all the time and so I think for me it was just like in some sense they really want to be this kind of comedian I wanted I want to be a comedian because of Eddie
点什么，所以我想随着我年龄的增长，我对这个世界有了更多的利害关系，我开始更多地关注新闻，就像我说的，我真的，我妈妈的，我以前是个独生子女，所以我经常和我妈妈在一起，她会在成年人周围，所以他们会身处，你知道的，很多经历过民权运动的黑人，他们会说，我们现在有工作了，但我们对世界的现状还是很生气，我一直听到这些对话，所以我想对我来说，这就像在某种意义上，我真的很想成为这种喜剧演员，我想成为一名喜剧演员是因为埃迪·
Murphy on starting out so that was not really like it wasn't like I came out like I got to be Gregory but I think I was attracted to that and then as a young comedian I was introduced to Bill Hicks when Bill Hicks was still like a folk tale he had passed away but it was just like somebody like handed me a tape of like listen to this I was like oh that that's that's what I want to do and then you like Chris Rock is a big influence and I got to be around Dave Chappelle a lot or like post South Africa and really watch him on stage a lot and just be like you know not that I'm any percentage of any of these comics
墨菲，刚开始的时候，所以那真的不像，我不是一出来就想成为格里高利，但我认为我被那个吸引了，然后作为一个年轻的喜剧演员，我接触到了比尔·希克斯，当时比尔·希克斯还像一个民间传说，他已经去世了，但就像有人递给我一盘磁带说“听听这个”，我就想，噢，那，那正是我想要做的，然后你就像克里斯·罗克是一个巨大的影响，我有很多机会和戴夫·查佩尔在一起，或者像南非之行后，在舞台上真正地看着他很多，然后就想，你知道的，并不是说我是这些喜剧演员中的任何百分比
but really that's the thing I'm attracted to doing is like speaking my mind and taking a stand just I would rather be Kevin Hart that doesn't seem easy but it does seem more cost efficient. So how often are you traveling around the country not not eight weeks a year with eight episodes you're doing you're doing maybe probably eight months yeah yeah I mean we shoot I mean the shows are pretty quickly shot people don't realize this but we shoot in like a seven-day week and but yeah it takes up most of the year with the editing and then after that like whatever time is left over I still do
但我真正被吸引去做的事情是——畅所欲言并表明立场，只是我宁愿做凯文·哈特，那看起来并不容易，但它确实看起来更具成本效益。所以你多久在全国各地旅行一次？不是一年八周配八集，你做的是，你大概要做八个月，是的，是的，我是说我们拍摄，我是说节目拍摄得相当快，人们没有意识到这一点，但我们大约在一个七天的一周内拍摄，但是是的，加上剪辑，它占去了大部分时间，然后在那之后，无论剩下什么时间，我仍然会
because I am on CNN instead of doing stand-up gigs I do lecture tours which pay better like I do a lot of colleges and private gigs like sort of talking about the work and that was my year up until the coronavirus. I want to ask you about two well many episodes I mean we could we could we could take the entire time on this podcast episode to talk about even one of your episodes but one of the fascinating ones was the first episode one of the first episodes you you met with a KKK member in Kentucky and Arkansas I think and several KKK members yeah and so which is this is fascinating how does a black man even
因为我在CNN工作，我不做单口喜剧演出，而是做讲座巡演，报酬更高，我做很多大学和私人演出，大概是谈论这项工作，这就是我直到新冠肺炎爆发前的一年。我想问你关于两集，嗯，很多集，我是说我们可以，我们可以把整个播客的时间都花在讨论你的哪怕其中一集上，但其中最吸引人的一集之一是第一集，其中一集你是在肯塔基州和阿肯色州见了一位3K党成员，我想，还有好几位3K党成员，是的，所以这很吸引人，一个黑人怎么能
get in go into that and feel safe and how did that happen what does that phone call like and so the that was the pilot episode and again sort of coming off of like at that point CNN had Bourdain Lisa Ling Morgan Spurlock Mike Roe and so I was aware that like if they're gonna add any show I have to do something that none of those shows is going to do and the elevator pitch was black guy goes places he shouldn't was basically the elevator pitch for the show so where shouldn't the black guy go the number one place is a clan meeting so yeah there's for the pilot maybe the pilot won't go and I'll have a good story but
甚至深入其中并感到安全？这究竟是怎么发生的？那个电话是什么样子的？所以那是试播集，同样地，回想起来，当时CNN有波登、莉萨·玲、摩根·斯普洛克、迈克·罗，所以我意识到，如果他们要增加任何节目，我必须做一些那些节目都不会做的事情，而电梯推销就是“黑人去不该去的地方”，这基本上就是这个节目的电梯推销，所以黑人不该去哪里？首要地点就是3K党集会，所以，是的，对于试播集来说，也许试播集不会播出，我会有个好故事，但
also I have to do something that CNN will be like well nobody does this on our networks so I was my so once we decided to do the show that was my pitch and they pitched a lot of other things and I kept being like what about the clan and they're like fine I was like oh shit and then it was about like luckily I didn't see us but producers having to call clan chapters and be like hey can see an income hello hello and then you know hey can see an income with a black guy hello hello what about a black comedian and then we were left with like four groups who were like sure because they want to be on TV Wow because they want
同时我也必须做一些让CNN觉得“好吧，我们的网络上没有人这么做”的事情，所以我就是——一旦我们决定做这个节目，那就是我的推销方案，他们推销了许多其他东西，而我一直说：“3K党怎么样？”他们说：“好吧。”我说：“噢，靠。”然后就是——幸运的是，我没有看到我们，而是制片人不得不打电话给3K党分会，说：“嘿，CNN能来吗？喂，喂。”然后呢，“嘿，CNN能带个黑人来吗？喂，喂。”“带个黑人喜剧演员怎么样？”然后我们剩下大约四个组织，他们说：“行。”因为他们想上电视。哇！因为他们想
to be on TV because they wanted to be on TV because they figured just no publicity is bad publicity yeah so the clan thinks every white person really is secretly a fan of the clan so that like whoa even the white people watching them are gonna be like I know like we're gonna be watching like yeah these guys have a good point because you have to be that the producer told me he was like get to pretend like he was like down with them to get them to let us come right no way so come out with the guy that you the the Klansman that you interviewed did he did he try his best to give you Mr. Klansman to you doctor
上电视，因为他们想上电视，因为他们觉得“没有宣传是坏宣传”，是的，所以3K党认为每个白人其实暗地里都是3K党的粉丝，所以就像“哇，连看他们的白人都觉得‘我知道，就像我们会看着说：这几个人说得有道理’”，因为你必须——制片人告诉我，他当时说：“假装好像他，你知道的，和他们是一伙的，好让他们让我们去，对吧？”没门，所以，卡毛，你采访的那个家伙，那个3K党成员，他有没有尽最大努力让你尊称他为克兰先生，你，医生，
doctor Reverend Reverend doctor Reverend did he do his best to try to convince you that what their thinking is is not nuts and if so what was that sentence like well I think that first of all I talked to several so I went to a cross burning or as they call across lighting so it was like an actual clan meeting a clever as they say and then I talked to a guy named Dr. Thomas Robb who's from Harris around Harrison Arkansas who has like a I call it a compound he says a church tomato tomato and so I talked to several different versions of the clan and there's sort of some basic levels of like it's sort of related to the Fox
博士，牧师，牧师博士？他有没有尽最大努力试图让你相信他们的想法并不疯狂？如果是这样，那句话是怎么说的？好吧，我认为首先，我和几个人谈过，所以我去了一个十字架燃烧仪式，或者他们称之为十字架点燃仪式，所以那是一个真正的3K党集会，“克雷文”，正如他们所说，然后我和一个叫托马斯·罗布博士的人谈过，他来自阿肯色州哈里森周围，他有一个，我称之为大院，他说是一个教堂，“番茄，番茄”，所以我跟不同版本的3K党谈过，而且有一些基本层面的，这其实有点类似于福斯
News thing actually where they're like well we all know black people don't know how to police themselves I mean we all know that I mean so right so there's there's a way they talk to you as if like these are all facts right I mean we all know that you know obviously you'd rather be with your people and I would want to be and I'd like to be with my people obviously we don't want to have our people mixing and I was like well I'm married to a white lady convenient truth so there was a lot of like them sort of trying to sort of like I said they act as if these things are just common sense if we could just get past
新闻的事情，他们会说：“好吧，我们都知道黑人不知道如何维持治安，我的意思是，我们都知道这一点，我的意思是，所以——”是的，所以他们跟你说话的方式，就好像这些都是事实一样，对吧？我的意思是，我们都知道，显然你更愿意和你们自己人在一起，而我也想，我想和我们自己人在一起，显然我们不想让我们的族群融合，而我说：“好吧，我娶了一个白人妇女。”一个convenient truth（善意的谎言/方便的事实），所以有很多类似他们试图去——就像我说的，他们表现得好像这些事情只是常识，如果我们能抛开
the all the rhetoric we all know these things are true and so it was really and there was some like it was right around time Ferguson it happened so there was some heat around at that moment they wanted to scare me when I first got there and I just sort of stand back while they were like it just sort of like let them get out the bluster before we could talk and did you get the sense that when you were done talking this person like I would find it impossible for anyone to just having talked to you for five minutes to come away from a conversation with you and not like you and not want to be friends with you did
所有的辞藻，我们都知道这些事情是真的，所以这真的是——而且有一些，那正值弗格森事件发生前后，所以那个时刻周围有一些热度，他们刚到那里的时侯想吓唬我，而我只是站在一旁，当他们——只是让他们在我们可以交谈之前把狂妄自大发泄出来，你有没有这种感觉，当你跟这个人谈完话之后——我发现任何人只要跟你谈话五分钟，就不可能从跟你的对话中离开时不头喜欢你、不想跟你做朋友——你
you get the sense at the end that this guy would be like you know I we can be friends I mean I can still have my thoughts but we can still be like did you get the sense that maybe you had turned him a little bit there was multiple levels because again it was like Dr. Thomas Robb is a professional Klansman he's not gonna get turned because this is how he pays his rent basically he's not he's not invested but when I went to the clan meeting like the the cross burning I was there for several hours like three or four hours because we've got there during daylight and we had to wait for it to be pitch
有没有这种感觉，在最后这个家伙会觉得：“你知道的，我们可以做朋友，我的意思是，我仍然可以有我的想法，但我们仍然可以——”你有没有这种感觉，也许你稍微改变了他一点？有多个层面，因为再次强调，托马斯·罗布博士是一个职业3K党，他不会被改变，因为这是他付房租的方式，基本上，他并不投入，但当我去了3K党集会——那个十字架燃烧仪式，我在那里呆了几个小时，大约三四个小时，因为我们在白天到达，我们不得不等到天漆黑
black for them to burn the cross and so I was talking to them about the process in a way that you would like think of like a PBS show like how do you burn the cross where do you get the wood from what do you what do you use to light the cross and so at some point it becomes dudes talking about like home projects wow yeah you you rope-adope them into a conversation and pretty soon they realized oh my gosh we're just we're having fun with a guy that we're supposed to hate I guess and then some of them wouldn't talk to me at all like they would just stay clear because I think they were afraid of catching black
他们才点燃十字架，所以我一直在跟他们谈论这个过程，用一种你会觉得像是一个PBS（公共电视网）节目的方式：你们怎么点燃十字架？你们从哪里弄来的木头？你们用什么来点燃十字架？所以在某种程度上，这变成了几个家伙在讨论像“家庭装修项目”之类的话题。哇，是的，你用绳套把他们引入了一场对话，很快他们意识到：“噢，天哪，我们正和一个我们本该恨的家伙玩得很开心，我猜。”然后他们中的有些人根本不跟我说话，他们只是保持距离，因为我认为他们害怕被传染黑人
so they were like really not even so wait so when you're so when you're sitting there talking to them about like hey who's who's old in the lighter and all that kind of bullshit are they wearing their fucking robes and their stupid hats and everything well yeah we asked I mean we did ask them to come you know you got to come wearing the dress whites as we say for the for the purposes of CNN and so it was August and they talked about how hot it was under the robes and I said maybe you should have thought of that switch the big meeting December or something yeah yeah yeah so yeah they talked about how hot it is
气息，所以他们真的甚至——等等，所以当你在那里坐着和他们谈论，比如说，嘿，谁拿了打火机之类的废话时，他们穿着他们他妈的袍子和愚蠢的帽子以及所有的东西吗？嗯，是的，我们要求——我的意思是，为了CNN的目的，我们确实要求他们来的时候穿着我们所说的“白色礼服”，所以那是八月，他们谈论袍子底下有多热，我说也许你们应该在十二月左右举行那个盛大集会什么的，是的，是的，所以，是的，他们谈论有多热，
but it must have there must have been like a certain level of foolish on top of everything else they must have seemed in these stupid ass robes and their fucking hats and all the hoods and and spouting and talking about putting the lumber together for a fucking cross burning and how would you think there was ever a moment like where did you ever remember you're like looking at them and you got a sense that they did they ever feel with shame of like yeah I look like a fucking fool I am a fucking fool of a human being no I think I don't think that happens in the moment I think that happens years later if you look
但在所有这一切之上，必定有一种特定水平的愚蠢，他们穿着这些愚蠢透顶的长袍、他妈的帽子和所有的头套，口若悬河地谈论着把木材拼凑起来进行他妈的十字架燃烧，你怎么会觉得曾经有过这样一个时刻——你有没有记起你看着他们，你有一种感觉，他们有没有感到任何羞耻感，比如：“是的，我看起来像个他妈的傻瓜，我是一个他妈的愚蠢的人类？”不，我不认为那种事会当场发生，我认为那是几年后，如果你回
back up but no I think they were like we all had a cool jacket in high school right that made you feel like you were a million dollars and now you look back and be like you see an old picture you're like oh I can't believe I've ever wore that right have you noticed that in traveling around the country has it been a distractingly clear to you I mean certain parts of the country I would imagine it would be more more apparent have you noticed that come on I mean I think that for me that racism is like wine and there's just different versions of it like some of it's more full-bodied and some of it's more like someone's
头看的话，才会发生，不，我想他们会觉得：“我们在高中时都有过一件很酷的外套，对吧？它让你觉得自己价值百万，现在你回头看，你会想，你看到一张老照片，你会想，‘噢，我真不敢相信我竟然穿过那个’”，对吧？你有没有注意到，在全国各地旅行的过程中，它对你来说是否清晰得令人分心？我的意思是，国家的某些地方，我想它会更明显，你注意到了吗，卡毛？我的意思是，我认为对我来说，种族主义就像红酒，它只是有不同的版本，有些更醇厚，有些更像，有些人
more like this one's woody this one's got a little like but I'd say that like I don't think like living in I live in Oakland California over in Berkeley San Francisco there it's not that there's not racism here it's just the kind that I think is the kind I can get along with the best you know but like my dad lives in Mobile Alabama and I used to go there every summer and there are things about Mobile Alabama that I'm like it's at least friendlier here like you know like there's this there's that even with the feeling with racism there are things I like better about Mobile Alabama than I like about the Bay Area
更像这个带点木香味，这个有点像——但我想说，我不认为——住在——我住在加州奥克兰，在伯克利、旧金山，这并不是说这里没有种族主义，只是我认为那种是我最能与之和谐相处的种族主义，你知道的，但像我爸爸住在阿拉巴马州莫比尔，我以前每年夏天都去那里，关于阿拉巴马州莫比尔有一些事情，我想“这里至少更友好”，你知道的，就像有——即使带着对种族主义的感觉，阿拉巴马州莫比尔也有一些我比湾区更喜欢的地方，
it's just this is the kind of races Michael live with but I'll tell you this the only time I've been kicked out of a place because I was black was in Chicago and Berkeley you know what is that what's that look like what do you mean you got kicked out so when I was a teenager I live in Chicago and I was in a record store waiting for a friend of mine and I was in there for like you know an hour but you know which is not a long time to be a record store unless you're a 15 and black and I was starting to walk out of the record store and the security guard came behind me and grabbed me by the collar and was like I need to search
只是这是一种可以与之共存的种族主义，但我会告诉你这个，我唯一一次因为我是黑人而被赶出一个地方是在芝加哥和伯克利，你知道的，那是什么样的？你是什么意思你被赶出去了？所以当我还是个青少年的时候，我住在芝加哥，我在一家唱片店等我的一个朋友，我在那里待了大约，你知道的，一个小时，但这对于一家唱片店来说并不算长，除非你15岁还是黑人，我当时正要走出唱片店，保安从我身后走过来，抓住我的领子说：“我需要搜查你，你偷了东西。”我什么都没偷，我甚至不需要说那个，但是，并且他基本上没在我身上找到任何东西，如果他找到了我的吸入器，他说：“你有哮喘吗？”这就像是一个多么奇怪的问题，此时此刻，先生，你从哪里偷的那个哮喘？
you down you stole something hadn't stole anything I don't even need to say that but and I and he basically didn't find anything on me if he found my inhaler he's like do you have asthma which is like what a strange question to ask right now sir and who did you steal that asthma from the environment the toxic environment I was raised in so and he basically like literally bum rushed me and threw me out onto the street so I've been in Alabama a lot that's never happened and then when I was this happened 2015 so I was like an adult with two kids in Berkeley California and my wife who was white as I
环境，我长大的那个有毒的环境？所以他基本上就像——字面意思上——猛冲过来把我扔到了街上，所以我去过阿拉巴马州很多次，那种事从未发生过，然后当我——这发生在2015年，所以我是一个带着两个孩子的成年人，在加州伯克利，我那正如我所提到的那样白得不行的妻子和我们13周大的婴儿以及她的一些朋友在一家咖啡馆里，我走过去跟她打招呼并跟她聊天，咖啡馆里有人敲了敲咖啡馆的窗户，说：“从这儿滚出去！”因为他们以为我在打扰这四个白人妇女，他妈的真
mentioned was at a coffee shop with our 13-week-old baby and some of her friends and I went to go say hello to her and talk to her and the coffee shop knocked somebody in the coffee shop knocked on the window and said get out of here because I thought I was like bothering these four white ladies in the fucking way unbelievable so for me it's like you know I think there's a level of like the South has a level of like historical violence that we associate with the South that we think is always happening which definitely happens but it's not always happening but outside of the South there's there's racism that's like
令人难以置信，所以对我来说，你知道的，我认为某种程度上，南方有一种我们与南方联系在一起的历史暴力水平，我们认为它一直在发生，这确实发生了，但它并不总是发生，但在南方之外，有一种种族主义，就像——
like people in the South and they're being racist they actually know they're being racist a lot of times outside the South people do things that are racist and they're like no it was just because you were wearing a hat I didn't have nothing to do with you being black let me ask you let me ask you about this so to that let me ask you about that incident in in in Berkeley where you go up and you talk to your wife and somebody knocks in the window what ends up happening in that what's your reaction do you freak out you tell them to go fuck themselves do you have is there a confrontation here's the funny part so
南方的人在表现出种族主义时，他们实际上知道自己在表现出种族主义，很多时候在南方之外，人们做的事情带有种族主义色彩，他们却说：“不，这只是因为你戴着帽子，这跟我不知道你是个黑人没有任何关系。”让我问你，让我问你关于这个的事，对于这一点，让我问你关于伯克利那个事件的事，你走过去跟你妻子说话，有人敲窗户，最后那个事件怎么样了？你的反应是什么？你抓狂了吗？你叫他们滚蛋吗？你发生冲突了吗？有趣的部分来了，所以
this is like and you all have been in this position I'm some somewhat like this where somebody like because none of that was funny yeah we're finally at the funny part guys welcome to the funny part so when the person knocked on the cafe window in the Bay Area I'm a little bit extra famous out here so I looked up like yeah you have seen me on that TV show get out wait a minute no I wasn't in that movie so like there was just and I was like I was like yeah yeah it's me you know oh so it was like a real like like turn upside down that took me a second to even get my bearings back and then my wife saw my face and because
这就像——你们所有人都处于过这种位置，我有点像这样，当某人——因为那些一点都不好笑，是的，我们终于到了好笑的部分了，伙计们，欢迎来到好笑的部分——所以当那个人在湾区敲咖啡馆窗户时，我在这里稍微有点额外出名，所以我抬头看着就像：“对，你在那个电视节目里见过我，滚开。”等等，不，我没演那部电影，所以就像——有那么一瞬间，我心想：“对，对，是我，你知道的，噢，”所以这就像是一个真正的——就像天翻地覆一样，我花了一秒钟才重新找回方向，然后我妻子看到了我的脸色，因为
we've been together a long time she was like oh something racist happened let me see what's going on around here and then the woman from the coffee shop came out to really give me the like move along from these nice white ladies and that 180 must have made it extra difficult in that moment in particular the sort of the fall from yeah you because we've all done that same thing which is like yeah hey can I get a picture of course of course thanks just take it of me in my oh you want me to take a picture sorry and it's that same and but but then but then magnify it by a million right and so like you're doing from that to that
我们在一起很久了，她就想：“噢，有什么种族主义的事情发生了，让我看看这周围发生了什么。”然后咖啡馆的那个女人出来，真的打算对我下达那种“从这些漂亮的白人妇女身边移开”的逐客令，那180度的转变一定让那个特定的时刻变得格外艰难，那种从……的坠落，因为我们都做过同样的事情，那就是：“噢，嘿，我能拍张照片吗？”“当然，当然，谢谢，只给我拍一张，哦，你想让我帮你拍一张？抱歉。”就是那种同样的——但是，但是然后——将其放大一百万倍，对吧？所以就像你从那种状态变成那种状态，那一定
that must have been you know by the way speaking of pulling your pants down I was in a parking lot once with Bateman and we're coming out of the old Jerry's deli in the marina and we're about to go to work and I was standing there wearing sweatpants and he's like so I guess I'll see you I go yeah and he just pantsed me out of the blue underpants and sweats and it was I had something in my hand and my pants are in my hand lucky I didn't push you over like I used to finish the grade school we weren't 18 we were 35 at the time you know you were sweatpants that's what you're gonna get did you learn I want to ask you about
是个——顺便说一句，说到脱你的裤子，我有一次在停车场和贝特曼在一起，我们从滨海区的旧杰瑞熟食店出来，我们正要去工作，我站在那里穿着运动裤，他就像：“那我猜待会儿见”，我说：“好的”，他二话不说就把我的裤子扒了下来，只剩内裤和运动裤，我手里拿着东西，裤子在手里，幸亏我没把你推倒，就像我过去在小学里做的那样，我们当时不是18岁，我们当时35岁，你知道的，你穿运动裤，那就是你要付出的代价，你学到了吗？我想问你关于
another episode that you did on United States of America only and I and I'm sorry to bring this guy up again maybe you like to talk about him maybe you don't but I'm always fascinated with people who hate like the KKK and Richard Spencer yes and you you're encounter with Richard Spencer who is you know the self-proclaimed white supremacist with and in credited with the term alt right isn't that correct yeah and so again with the KKK Richard Spencer who's a very scary person how did you learn that interview and like you know why did he agree to that I mean he loves TV and I think he actually you know I think the
你在《美国全貌》中做的另一个节目，只有——我很抱歉再次提起这个家伙，也许你喜欢谈论他，也许你不喜欢，但对于像3K党和理查德·斯派塞这样心怀恨意的人，我总是很着迷，是的，你与理查德·斯派塞的相遇，他是，你知道的，自称的白人至上主义者，并被认为是“另类右翼”一词的发明者，难道不是吗？是的，所以同样地，对于3K党，理查德·斯派塞是一个非常可怕的人，你是怎么做那次采访的？以及，你知道的，他为什么同意那个？我的意思是，他热爱电视，而且我想他实际上，你知道的，
funny thing about him is that he's not as scary as he used to be because I think a lot of programs like mine sort of like here talk say more and the more he said the more even his like yikes so I think that like that was the time when I think I got a lot of criticism for that interview because people said I gave him a platform or I you know or there was all that talk about don't normalize people and I'm like this is America this dude this all these ideas are real and he's going to talk about it I think we got him because weirdly we got there before the point he got big and I think that we sort of like when we had him
关于他，有趣的是，他不像以前那么可怕了，因为我认为很多像我这样的节目，有点像——“来，说吧，说更多，”他说得越多，甚至连他的——哎呀，所以我认为那是——我认为那次采访我受到了很多批评，因为人们说我给他提供了一个平台，或者我，你知道的，或者有所有关于“不要让人们正常化”的讨论，而我说：“这是美国，这个家伙，所有这些想法都是真实的，他会谈论这个的，”我想我们得到他是因为奇怪的是我们在他变大之前就到了那里，并且我认为我们有点像——当我们让他
agree to do it he was like this sort of unknown guy by the time we filmed it he had become more known and by time he aired he was like a national figure but people didn't realize when I talked to him he hadn't been punched in the face yet so people like why didn't you punch him in the face well first of all not really my style but also that's not how time works so I could just right but yeah I mean I got a lot of heat from the left for that interview because I was talking to this guy who was such a demagogue and it's like but I sort of I feel like that's part of my job and I'm not I don't feel like I'm giving him a
同意去做时，他还是个无名小卒，等我们拍摄时，他已经变得更有名了，等节目播出时，他已经成了一个全国性人物，但人们没有意识到，当我跟他谈话时，他还没有挨过耳光，所以人们会问：“你为什么不扇他一巴掌？”好吧，首先，这真的不是我的风格，而且时间也不是那样运作的，所以我也许可以——但，是的，我因为那次采访受到了左翼的大量攻击，因为我在跟这个如此煽动民粹的家伙谈话，就像——但我某种程度上觉得那是我的工作的一部分，而且我不觉得我是在给他提供一个
platform because I I was there to talk with him too I didn't go Richard you take this segment I'm gonna go to chill out you know I was there to talk with well it's also it's a great venue that you've created to make us aware of these people and these problems and these social issues you know I don't think there's anything wrong with that can I shift gears for a second so how did you what was your start in stand-up how did how did that happen I mean you know signed up at a coffee shop paid 99 cents to perform I was really I was a kid who was a comedy nerd before that was a thing so I just really loved I was like a
平台，因为我，我也去那里跟他谈话，我没有说：“理查德，你来主持这个环节，我去冷静一下，”你知道的，我是去和——好吧，这也是你创造的一个绝佳的平台，让我们意识到这些人、这些问题以及这些社会问题，你知道的，我认为这没什么不对的，我能换个话题吗？所以你是怎么开始讲单口喜剧的？那是怎么发生的？我的意思是，你知道的，在一家咖啡馆报名，付99美分去表演，我真的，我是一个在“喜剧书呆子”这个词流行之前就已经是个喜剧书呆子的小孩，所以我真的很喜欢，我当时就像是一个
you know my friends would be like did you hear the new public enemy song I was like did you see the new young comedian especially with Jan Caram and Dennis Miller like I was just like a real lover of stand-up comedy from from back in the day like remember seeing Seinfeld on the Tonight Show with Johnny Carson and like all these things were it's like I just loved that I loved it you know so it's just it was like but I also when I started doing it I was also not funny for a very long time so it took me a long time to do that thing they call finding your voice it took me a long time to figure out and I think because the
你知道的，我的朋友们会说：“你听过最新的‘公敌’乐队的歌吗？”我会说：“你看到那个新来的年轻喜剧演员了吗，特别是詹·卡拉姆和丹尼斯·米勒？”我只是一个单口喜剧的真正的爱好者，从过去的日子开始，就像记得在约翰尼·卡森主持的《今夜秀》上看到宋飞，以及所有这些事情，就像我只是喜欢那个，我喜欢那个，你知道的，所以这就像是——但我也，当我开始做这件事时，我在很长一段时间里也并不好笑，所以我花了很长时间才做到他们所谓“找到你的声音”的事情，我花了很长时间才弄明白，并且我认为因为那些
things I wanted to do I was afraid to do so it took me a long time to to actually figure out how I wanted to do it it's one of the scariest jobs on I mean I've never done stand-up and it's just you know the scariest thing to me seems to be getting out there it's so because it's just you and your thoughts and like this is what I think is funny let's hope you do too so here we you know yeah I was terrible at it did you never did it well did you do a Jason now ever I know I haven't I would be I would be petrified for sure because I would imagine that the the sweet spot comes when you can kind of match your your your mood or
我想做的事情，我害怕去做，所以我花了很长时间才真正弄清楚我想怎么做它。这是世界上最吓人的工作之一，我的意思是，我从未做过单口喜剧，而它——你知道的，对我来说最吓人的事情似乎就是走上台去，它如此——因为只有你和你的想法，而这正是“我认为这很好笑，希望你也这么觉得”，所以在这里，我们——你知道的，我在这方面太糟糕了，你从未把它做好过吗？你有没有过一个杰森的时刻？我知道我没有，我肯定会被吓坏的，因为我能想象到，当你可以把你的情绪或
your attitude with with your with your humor as well in other words if all you have are the jokes if the jokes aren't great you're not going to get last but if you can marry some sort of some sort of attitude or vibe or or tone then the audience is perhaps more sort of sort of preconditioned to like that joke I mean I bet it's a marriage between the two there was always the knock on Dane cook right there they said that he didn't have it like lots of jokes I'm not really that familiar but like but he had a lot of attitude right lent itself right so people were kind of enjoying his energy and the jokes but it was a
态度与你的幽默完美契合时，那个绝佳的时机就会到来，换句话说，如果你所有的只有笑话，如果笑话不够好，你就不会获得笑声，但如果你能将某种态度、氛围或基调结合起来，那么观众也许就更倾向于喜欢那个笑话，我的意思是，我敢打赌这是两者之间的结合，人们总是对戴恩·库克有所非议，对吧？他们说他没有——就像有很多笑话，我其实不太熟悉，但是——但他有很多态度，对吧？这很契合，所以人们有点喜欢他的能量和笑话，但这是一种
kind of a combination of the two as opposed to somebody who just goes out there and just says you know so a dentist and a rabbi walk like it's you are you're you're fully reliant on the content of the joke and there's no personality with I failed miserably at it I was I was horrible at it I my opening joke whenever I would go out is this so bad nobody laughed it was um you know they say doing ballet is one of the most difficult things you could do so I say don't do it hmm boy yeah so come on it was funny because it was so like it's like it's like it's like a New Yorker cartoon yeah it is it is it was horrible
两者的结合，而不是那种走上台去只是说：“你知道的，一个牙医和一个拉比走进——”就像你是——你完全依赖于笑话的内容，而没有任何个性。我在这方面彻底失败了，我太糟糕了，我的开场白——每当我上台时，都是这样的——太糟糕了，没有人笑，它是：“你知道的，他们说跳芭蕾是你能做的事情中最困难的事情之一，所以我说——别去跳。”嗯，天哪，是的，卡毛，这很有趣，因为它太——就像是一个《纽约客》杂志的漫画，是的，它是，它是，太糟糕了。
Jason Jason whatever happened with that the dentist and the rabbi though so yes so let me finish so the dentist goes in there and the rabbi is yeah guys come on pay attention I want to give us all whiplash here and I want I want to go back to something because I really I want to know your opinion on this come out how old are your kids nine five and a half and two okay how old do you think it is well when do you think kids should learn about black history I've got a 13 year old and an eight year old two girls and what is the perfect age where a kid is smart enough to hear the lesson and say Jesus I'm glad we're past the
杰森，杰森，那个牙医和拉比的故事到底怎么回事？所以，是的，让我说完，所以牙医进去了，然后拉比是——嘿，伙计们，注意听，我不想让我们所有人都得鞭笞伤，我想要——我想回到某个话题，因为我真的，我想知道你对这个的看法，卡毛，你的孩子多大了？九岁、五岁半和两岁，好吧，你认为多大——你认为孩子们什么时候应该了解黑人历史？我有一个13岁的和一个8岁的，两个女孩，什么是完美的年龄，让一个孩子足够聪明，能够听到这个教训，并说：“天哪，我很高兴我们已经度过了
teeth of that and we still have a lot of work to root out the rest of the racism but do you know what I mean so it's so here's the thing with my with our oldest daughter who was four when the cafe thing happened when that happened we realized me my wife realized that we had talked to our daughter about race which is a different conversation than racism so the race conversation is like madam CJ Walker was the first woman to be a self-made millionaire in this country and she made hair products or Michael Jordan is a great basketball player like that's the race conversation about great things that people of this
那个最艰难的时期，而且我们仍然有很多工作要做，以根除其余的种族主义”？但你知道我的意思吗？所以——事情是这样的，对于我们的大女儿，当咖啡馆的事情发生时，她当时四岁，当那件事发生时，我和我妻子意识到，我们曾跟我们的女儿谈论过“种族”（race），这与谈论“种族主义”（racism）是不同的对话，所以“种族”对话就像是：玛丽·C·J·沃克是这个国家第一个白手起家的女百万富翁，她生产护发产品，或者迈克尔·乔丹是一个伟大的篮球运动员，这就是关于这个种族的人所取得的伟大成就的“种族”对话，
race had done yeah but the racism conversation we hadn't had and at some point I realized as a black guy who's raising a black girl who's also mixed race because her mom is half white that if at some point she learns that outside the house then I've been negligent if the first time my kid hears the word slavery is from a teacher who I don't know necessarily gonna talk about it in the right way to me it feels like not teaching your kid to like go to the bathroom when they need to go to the bathroom it's like it's a thing that you need to teach as a parent in the household I think parents of color black
是的，但关于“种族主义”的对话我们还没有进行过，而在某种程度上，我意识到作为一个抚养黑人女孩的黑人母亲——她也是混血儿，因为她妈妈是混血白人——如果在某个时候她在屋外了解到这一点，那我就是疏忽了，如果我的孩子第一次听到“奴隶制”这个词是从一个我不知道是否一定会以正确方式谈论它的老师那里听到的，对我来说，这感觉就像是不教你的孩子在需要上厕所时去上厕所，这就像是你作为父母在家里需要教导的一件事情，我认为有色人种父母，黑人
parents we really understand that and over index on that and I think white parents a lot of times like you said are sort of a little bit like I don't want them to take the wrong idea but we also forget the kids have a really good moral compass generally so all the conversations about racism they understand what's fair and what's not fair I think the things adults are afraid of is not being able to understand explain why slavery happened to a kid but for me the best thing about that I've done with my kid is like I have no idea and to me owning the fact that letting my kid know that like this is horrible she'd be like
父母，我们真正理解这一点，并在这一点上过度发挥，而白人父母很多时候——就像你说的——有点像“我不想让他们产生错误的观念”，但我们也忘记了孩子们通常都有很好的道德罗盘，所以所有关于种族主义的对话，他们都明白什么是公平的，什么是不公平的，我认为成年人害怕的是无法向孩子解释为什么会发生奴隶制，但对我来说，我对我孩子做过的最好的事情就是——我不知道，对我来说，承认这个事实，让我的孩子知道这很可怕，她会说：“但是为什么？他们为什么要这样做？”我不认为他们只是不认为黑人真的和白人一样，但为什么呢？有一个“为什么”的层面，所有父母在很多事情上都会遇到，比如“为什么天空是蓝的？”而天空是蓝的，我们觉得可以坦然地说：“我不知道，它就是蓝的。”我认为在种族主义的讨论中，同样好的一点是，我说：“我真的无法向你解释，但这就是发生的事情，”而对我来说，重要的是我的孩子们对这种公平和正义的体系有一种感觉，他们把这种体系应用到分一半饼干上，如果他们把这个应用到种族主义上，每一个
but why why would they do that I don't think that they just didn't think black people really were the same as white people but why there's a level of why that all parents get to with lots of things like why is the sky blue with the sky is blue we feel comfortable going I don't know it's just blue I think it's fine with the racism discussion also good to point I'm going I really can't explain it to you but this is what happened and I for me it's important that my kids have a sense of that really that same system of fairness and justice they apply to like splitting a cookie in half if they apply that to racism every
但为什么，他们为什么要这么做？我不认为他们只是单纯地觉得黑人和白人真的不一样。但为什么呢？所有父母在面对很多事情时都会遇到“为什么”的层级，比如为什么天空是蓝的？天空是蓝的，我们觉得说“我不知道，它就是蓝的”没什么问题，我觉得在讨论种族主义时也一样，好的一点是，我要说：“我真的无法向你解释，但事实就是这样。”对我来说，重要的是我的孩子们对那种公平和正义的系统有一种感觉，就像他们分半块饼干时应用的那个系统一样，如果他们把这个应用到种族主义上，无论
lot about World War two in European history and I was reading this book and my kids were asking about World War two and I had to explain to them my oldest son was probably seven and a half at the time he's now 11 and explained to him about World War two and the Holocaust and he was like what is it and I was like holy shit I can't believe I'm at this moment where I've got to explain to him what the Holocaust is and I and I was like well it's a truth it's a reality I can try to serve it to him in a way that's not too frightening to a seven year old but also that's not not hiding what happened I said you know and you
欧洲历史里有很多关于二战的内容，当时我正在读一本书，我的孩子们在问关于二战的事，我不得不向他们解释。我大儿子当时大概七岁半，他现在11岁了。我向他解释了二战和大屠杀，他的反应是“那是什么？”，当时我就想，天哪，我竟然迎来了这一刻，必须向他解释什么是大屠杀。我当时觉得，这是一个真相，是一个现实，我可以试着用一种对七岁小孩来说不是那么可怕、但也没有隐瞒发生过的事情的方式讲给他听。我说，你知道吗，你
explained to him that six million Jews and then an additional 20 million people were murdered and that's a big fucking scary notion and I just remember him thinking like that same thing you were saying of like but why did they do that yeah why did they hate Jewish people like imagine if you were Jewish like how you would explain that to Archie and then Archie thinks wait people hated us at some point and like that's just you want to make sure that they're old enough to be able to say oh well that's just like those people were fucking idiots and I'll never be anything like that and work as hard as I can the whole
向他解释了有六百万犹太人以及另外两千万无辜民众被谋杀，这真是一个极其恐怖骇人的概念。我只记得他在想——就像你刚才说的那种感觉——但他们为什么要这么做？是的，他们为什么那么恨犹太人？想象一下如果你是犹太人，你会怎么向阿奇（Archie）解释这个。然后阿奇就会想，等等，人们在某个时候竟然恨过我们？这就好比，你想确保他们已经长到足够大，能够说“哦，那些人真是群白痴，我绝不会变成那种人，我这辈子都会竭尽全力
life to keep that away you know there's there's a there is an age I think where kids are too young to put that in its right size you know but I think we make those decisions all the time about our kids like what what level of the where do babies come from conversation do you get into them at some point kids want to know and you can go the stork if you want to but then at some point if you go too far down the stork road then you got to like man now they're 17 stork got all these great kids come from yeah exactly so I feel like you know I mean in the same way that like I didn't grow up believing in Santa Claus because
远离那种事”。你知道的，我觉得孩子们在某个年龄段还太小，无法正确理解那种事情的体量。但我觉得我们一直在为孩子们做这样的决定，比如，关于“小孩是从哪里来的”这种对话，你到底要进行到什么程度？在某个时刻，孩子们会想要知道，如果你愿意的话，你可以拿“送子鸟”的故事搪塞过去。但到了某个阶段，如果你把送子鸟的故事讲得太深，你就会想：“天哪，现在他们17岁了，还觉得所有伟大的孩子都是送子鸟带来的呢。”对，确实如此。所以我觉得，就像我小时候不相信圣诞节有圣诞老人一样，因为
my mom was like no no I'm a single parent I bought all this shit you know but my wife grew up believing in Santa Claus and she wanted our kids believe in Santa Claus and so it's like I guess we're gonna believe in Santa Claus we all the time with our kids we create these ways or we let them believe in things that aren't real we create all these fairy tales my kid thinks unicorns are real and I'm like okay for now we'll do that so I think we're always making those kinds of decisions and for me as a black parent I feel like I can't hide all that other stuff because again I don't want that stuff to come in a way that I can't
我妈妈说：“不，不，我是个单亲妈妈，这些东西全是我花钱买的。”但我的妻子从小相信有圣诞老人，她希望我们的孩子们也相信圣诞老人。所以我就想，好吧，那我们就相信圣诞老人吧。我们总是这样和孩子们在一起，我们创造这些方式，或者让他们去相信一些并不真实的事情，我们创造了所有这些童话故事。我的孩子觉得独角兽是真的，而我的态度是“好吧，暂时先这样吧，我们配合一下”。所以我觉得我们一直在做这种决定。作为一个黑人父母，我觉得我不能把所有那些其他的事情都藏起来，因为同样地，我不希望这些事情以一种我无法
control and I think we all have a and we all know our kids and we all know there's a level that with your kid will go okay that's enough for today I want to go do something else and you don't go no I'm not done talking about the transatlantic slave trade I think you go do other things right so is this why you're a part of Race Forward which is kind of like a think-take yeah I to me it's important to now that I've been identified as a public figure and entertainer who does this work and the thing that I can do for people in places like Race Forward or like the ACLU is go here's how the people are receiving the
控制的方式突然降临。而且我觉得我们都很清楚，我们也了解自己的孩子，每个人都知道当你的孩子听到一定程度时会说：“好吧，今天就到这里吧，我想去干别的了。”你总不能说：“不行，我还没讲完跨大西洋奴隶贸易呢。”你肯定会让他们去做别的对吧？所以，这就是你加入“Forward种族前进”组织的原因吗？那有点像是一个智库。是的，对我来说，既然我已经成为了一个公众人物和会做这种工作的艺人，这就很重要。我能为像“Forward种族前进”或美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）这样地方的人们做的事情就是去告诉他们：人们是如何接收到
message is there more information I can give them that you're a lot of times these places don't know how to get the information of the people the way the people can take and so as an entertainer I can be like oh I can take this big complicated idea you have and break it into bite-sized chunks so yeah which is what your show is kind of like exactly yeah that's what I'm hoping to do Sean were you really confused when when they were saying yeah defund the police were you like why is Stuart Copeland needs money too I mean part of the police because I see your shirt there were you were you feeling like the police
这个信息的？还有没有什么更多的信息我可以提供给他们？很多时候，这些机构并不知道如何以大众能够接受的方式将信息传递出去。因此，作为一个艺人，我可以做到：“噢，我可以把你那些宏大而复杂的主意拆解成容易消化的小块。”所以是的，你的节目有点像是这种感觉。完全正确，是的，这正是我希望做到的。肖恩，当他们说“撤资警察”的时候，你真的感到很困惑吗？你当时是不是在想“斯图尔特·科普兰（Stuart Copeland）也需要钱吗？”我的意思是，警察乐队……因为我看到你穿着那件衬衫，你当时是不是觉得警察……
was it gonna well this is a band a group because you know it's different right they weren't saying take money away in the band the police so wait let me understand so you're saying they were saying like sting they have to take all his bass guitars away they weren't gonna do that okay I get it come out what part of the show do you love the most from like a technical and like do you see this as as a jumping-off point to become more of an actor more of a director more of a writer more of a producer all of the above like what do you what ideally would be your next your next venture and entertainment finally we
事情会……好吧，这是一个乐队，一个组合，因为你知道这不一样，对吧？他们当时可不是说要从“警察乐队”里扣钱。所以等等，让我理清一下，你是说他们是说要把斯汀（Sting）所有的低音吉他都没收吗？他们可没打算那么干。好吧，我明白了。说出来吧，从技术层面或者其他方面来说，你最喜欢节目的哪一部分？你是否把这看作是一个跳板，从而成为一名更多的演员、更多的导演、更多的编剧、更多的制作人，还是以上皆是？理想情况下，你的下一个娱乐事业会是什么？最后，我们
can talk about my ideas for the next season of Ozark okay here we go finally finally yeah I don't really see my I don't see myself as an actor I see myself as somebody who is now it's my job to produce and bring other people into shows like this that wouldn't normally have access to host a show like this I think the reason why that like the thing about me that connects me to a Bourdain is neither one of us was like a journalist who got a TV show we were both like people who were like in our lives doing our thing who then ended up with these shows and I think the more people we bring in from outside of
终于可以聊聊我对《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）下一季的想法了。好吧，我们开始吧，终于开始了。是的，我其实并不觉得自己是个演员，我觉得自己是一个这样的人：现在我的工作是去制作节目，并将其他平时根本没有机会主持这类节目的其他人带入到这样的节目中。我觉得，我之所以能和安东尼·波登（Bourdain）产生共鸣，原因在于我们俩都不是那种得到了电视节目的记者，我们俩都是过着自己生活、做好自己事情的人，然后阴差阳错地拥有了这些节目。而且我觉得，我们从外面带进来的人越多
Hollywood to do these things that the shows become more interesting so I really do want to produce and bring in more diverse voices to shows like this yeah that's my goal and I've started and I directed a documentary about Chris Rock a year or so ago and so I do also want to produce a director I can't you know I really don't want to have to be relying on this face forever it's pandemic and hard so so non nonfiction stuff is where you'd love to you'd love to stay yeah it's and socially relevant issues and yeah I mean I think for me it's always socially relevant even if it's not stated like the Chris Rock
好莱坞来做这些事情，节目就会变得越有趣。所以我真的很想制作节目，并将更多多元化的声音引入到这样的节目中。是的，这就是我的目标。我已经开始了，大约一年多前我导演了一部关于克里斯·洛克（Chris Rock）的纪录片，所以我确实也想做制作人和导演。我真的不想余生都靠这张脸过活，疫情期间太难了。所以非虚构类的东西是你最想继续坚持的领域吗？是的，而且是具有社会意义的议题。我的意思是，对我来说，它总是具有社会意义的，即使它没有明确表露出来，就像克里斯·洛克那部
documentary I did Chris is socially relevant but it was also just me as a comedy nerd wanting to talk about the his special bring the pain so I don't think it always has to be like you know it's not always medicine I think that like it's something like these are things I happen to be interested in I think it is great when you can bring in sort of bigger themes into all these things because I think all everything we do has a bigger theme in it and I think it's great to sort of be able to bring those themes out but no I also you know there are things I want to do that are fun too yeah it's not it's not always
纪录片一样，克里斯本身就具有社会意义，但这也是我作为一个喜剧迷，想要谈论他的特别节目《带来痛苦》（Bring the Pain）的个人愿望。所以我不认为它必须永远像是在吃药一样，它不一定非得是某种说教。我觉得这只是我碰巧感兴趣的一些事情。当你能把一些更宏大的主题融入到所有这些事情中时，那就太棒了。因为我觉得我们所做的一切都包含着一个更宏大的主题，能够把这些主题挖掘出来是一件很棒的事。不过不，我也有些我想去做的、很有趣的事情，对吧？它并不总是
this didactic do you agree with this idea that maybe it would be better or it would it would expand and make it more enjoyable in season four of Ozark if Marty died do you know what no one's saying Jason stop cutting people I'm listening I'm listening if a new guy came into town I got it a little bit taller a little more handsome it's kind of like a shorter haircut maybe maybe north of the border some pipes it is our last season I might I might die it's the last season I mean you never know you know I don't let that happen kill all my dreams I mean you know just to be clear with was Ozark there are bigger
这种说教式的。你同不同意这样一种观点：也许在《黑钱胜地》第四季中，如果马蒂（Marty）死了，节目会变得更好，或者说它的延展性和可看性会更强？你知道吗……没人说话，杰森，别打断别人，我在听，我在听。如果一个新人来到镇上，我明白了，个子稍微高一点，长得更帅一点，发型稍微短一点，也许在边境以北，还有点歌喉……这确实是我们最后一季了，我可能会死，这是最后一季，我的意思是，你永远说不准，你知道的……我绝不允许这种事发生，别毁了我的梦想！我的意思是，你知道的，为了把话说清楚，关于《黑钱胜地》这部剧，其实有更大的
themes in that show other than just like this and I might and I'm just to be 100% transparent huge fan of Ozark there and one of there are bigger things in that show than just yeah all to all three of you you're doing sure yeah no thanks yeah thanks but there are there are I'm it's also like an exciting show to watch but there are bigger themes in that show that that come through so I don't think it I don't think the things have to be always so you could do a documentary about that place but it's also they can come through in an in a fictional way well listen let me just say from everybody at Jason's production
主题在里面，而不仅仅是……而且我（说这话要100%坦诚）是《黑钱胜地》的超级大粉丝……那里面的主题要比……是的，谢谢你们三个，你们做得很好。不，谢谢，谢谢。但确实有，这也是一部看得很过瘾的剧，而且其中蕴含的宏大主题也自然流露出来了。所以我不认为……我不认为事情必须总是……你可以为那个地方拍一部纪录片，但这些主题也可以通过虚构的方式展现出来。好吧，听着，请允许我代表杰森的制作公司
company with prehands productions yes that we're so we're so grateful prehands productions well I come out I want to thank I want to thank you for being here today you thank you for taking the time and and and I really truly mean I'm a huge fan thank you for teaching me shit that I would have not had any other access to and really enlightening me and and millions of other people and so I appreciate you and I appreciate what you do thank you thank you my friend good to see you thank you for joining us pal thank you come out wow thanks man see you later all right thanks bye so I've always loved him because well I met him in
Prehands Productions的所有人说一声，是的，我们真的是……非常感激……Prehands Productions……好吧，我要出来说，我要感谢你今天能来这里，谢谢你抽出时间。我是真心实意地讲，我是你的超级大粉丝。谢谢你教给我那些我通过其他任何途径都接触不到的知识，真的启迪了我以及千千万万其他人。所以我很感激你，也很感激你所做的工作。谢谢你，谢谢你，我的朋友，很高兴见到你。谢谢你加入我们，老兄。谢谢你，出来吧。哇，谢谢老哥，再见啦。好的，谢谢，拜拜。我一直都很喜欢他，因为……嗯，我在
Sundance like I don't know a couple years ago and that's when I got to learn about his show and him and a fascinating background fascinating guy super smart super on it like and I love those kinds of shows where they do all the homework for you it's like a documentary every episode and you're like you just get like the the nuts and bolts of what you need to know and what you need to learn and I just love him I think that's what they're saying about our show you know that word we're really educating people yeah I don't think that I don't think there's a single person saying that really no I don't think that there I love
圣丹斯电影节（Sundance）上认识他的，大概是几年前吧。也就是那个时候，我开始了解他的节目、了解他本人。他有着迷人的背景，是个迷人的人物，超级聪明，对状况了如指掌。我就是喜欢那种为观众做好所有功课的节目，每一集都像是一部纪录片，你只需要获取你需要知道和学习的核心干货就行了。我就是很喜欢他。我觉得他们在评价我们的节目时也是这么说的，你知道的，就好像我们在真正教育人们一样。是的，我觉得没有一个人会这么说，真的。我不觉得……我喜欢
that Sean I love that you admit this is my this is my vision of you it's just like you you and Scott you have a nice meal right probably tuna salad on white bread with potato chips with exactly right and his bite plate soaking in a cup I think I should start every episode with an element to keep going and then you just sit on the couch and you're like and then you turn the TV and then there's a switch for your brain and you just turn it off right and you and it's everything you wear a bib because of the drool yeah and you're like well my brain with new stuff you pretty much you pretty much got me nailed that that's
这一点，肖恩，我喜欢你承认这一点。这就是我对你的想象：你和斯科特（Scott）在一起吃一顿美餐，对吧？可能是在白面包上夹金枪鱼沙拉，旁边配着薯片，完全没错。然后他的牙托正泡在一杯水里……我觉得我应该在每一集开始时都加入一个元素来维持下去，而你呢，就坐在沙发上，然后……你打开电视，你的大脑就像有个开关一样，直接就关掉了。然后你……你甚至因为流口水而需要围上围兜，对吧？然后你会说……我的大脑吸收了新东西……你基本上把我给说透了，这就是
that's me to a T right here's what I picture you will I picture you every night after your arugula salad sitting in front of the television but there's a mirror on top of it right so you can look at yourself watching the TV is that right I got rid of the television all together I was like what are we doing why are we playing this game this is all I really want to watch cut to the goddamn chase all right it's just a staring contest but but what a what a what a cool what a cool dude and what a funny guy and great guest Sean thanks yeah I love you guys you guys keep nailing it with your guests yeah well what's going on
百分之百的我！以下是我脑海中想象的你，沃尔（Will）：我想象你每天晚上吃完芝麻菜沙拉后，坐在电视机前，但在电视机上方装了一面镜子，这样你就可以一边看电视一边看着自己，是这样吗？我早就把电视机彻底扔掉了。我当时想：“我们在干什么？我们为什么要玩这种游戏？这根本不是我真正想看的，直接给我看干脆利落的结局吧！”好吧，这其实只是一场大眼瞪小眼的比赛。不过话说回来，他真是一个太酷、太牛的人，也是个非常搞笑的家伙，绝对是个棒极了的嘉宾。谢谢你，肖恩。是的，我爱你们，你们一直在用你们的嘉宾阵容大获成功。好吧，最近怎么样
man I mean can you don't make us replace you because if you don't start bringing the heat with your guests we're not rolling anymore right we will let me listen yeah we are inches away with there are this close we've had we've had three open call auditions for your spot we haven't found anybody yet but we are real fucking what yeah no way what if I came in and I auditioned in a disguise I mean this isn't it like Bobby Valentine with your Rolodex and these are the people I can bring no your guests are incredible I I'm so flattered and stunned by the people that that we three have gotten so far right it's very humbling yeah yeah this has
老兄？我的意思是，你能不能别逼我们换掉你？因为如果你再不通过你的嘉宾阵容把热度带起来，我们就不干了，对吧？我们会的……听着，是的，我们真的只差几英寸了，就差这么一点点。我们已经为你的位置进行了三轮公开招募面试，虽然我们还没找到合适的人选，但我们真的很他妈……什么？怎么可能！如果我化了妆来参加面试呢？我的意思是，这难道不像鲍勃·瓦伦丁（Bobby Valentine）带着你的通讯录来一样吗？这些人都是我能请来的……不，你的嘉宾阵容简直不可思议。我们三个能请到目前为止的这些人，我感到无比荣幸和震惊，真的非常谦卑。是的，是的，这
been an amazing thing to be part of such a huge long rollout of a Ozark press tour we're trying to hide it but it's it's come out came it came it was a little little not subtle there on that last level there whoever it is Ted I'm gonna call Sarandos and I'm calling the MRC and I'm like where's my paycheck Ted Sarandos runs Netflix thank you for one of these days I'm gonna fucking lose it this is all right well we'll chat we'll see you guys next episode hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey nice Vice There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
真的是一段不可思议的经历，能参与到《黑钱胜地》如此庞大且漫长的宣传巡演中。我们本来想隐瞒的，但它还是暴露了，刚才在最后一个环节里多多少少有点不够低调。不管是谁，泰德，我要给萨兰多斯（Sarandos）打电话，我要给MRC打电话，然后质问他们：“我的薪水在哪儿？”泰德·萨兰多斯可是运营网飞（Netflix）的人啊！谢谢你，总有一天我要气疯了。好吧，我们聊到这儿，下一集再见啦！嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，太棒了，副总裁！本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。